what was it like being an on a course
reporter I can definitely give you a
piece of advice if you call Charles
Barkley a fat ass they will not give you
the drink that you requested on the golf
course
[Applause]
[Music]
at the Tootsie Roll right there
sorry as soon as he got on air Chuck I
turned you down
all right go ahead
that's my partner
I like that Partners really good yeah so
good
you know it doesn't bother me I know
that the little things bother you Jordan
yeah that's fair I teed that one out
trash talk in the locker room it's the
greatest thing that's the only thing I
miss stay up stay up yep boom
boom it's kind of nice kind of shape one
here
[Applause]
[Music]
I hit it really good that needs to bite
bomb touch them all JT
well done man
[Applause]
Chuck's looking at that Moon like it's
an oreo
[Laughter]
flyer no
stay up stay up yeah
good job
turn turn
man we really needed that
because we got to we got to make this
thing go the whole 12 holes because I
know trt got another 795 commercials
KT
M
be good Parsi be right
let's let's come back here too this is
about back too getting better come on
talk to me feeling better to me I forgot
to tell you guys tiger gets a stroke
here so
please don't piss him off guys
Rory it's good yeah pick it up
you guys did not just do that yeah
I could feel it I knew you guys were up
to someone
oh my goodness that's Karma okay no we
deserve that
oh like that
oh my goodness
I cannot wait to try that shot tomorrow
Chuck owes me a dinner he lost a couple
years ago on on an iron ball bet and he
still hadn't paid I do owe you money as
soon as I found Applebee's down here
we're going back
foreign
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
he's lifting the left Hill on that one
yeah there you go I grew a little bit
good job
that would be nice to drive the ball
like that Charles that's just beautiful
effortless too
oh yeah
oh some sauce on it
please hook more there's a hook spinner
here we go here comes
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
there it is that's a winner
I mean come on like a little bit
[Applause]
hold on good plan